Hãy bỏa tình thái nguyên tổ chức lẽ truy tàng quân trường bỏa tổ quốc khá bà của chúng tình gước
đối với chúng ta ra gà quang 2, vì đã có thành tích phút sắc nổ xuất trong thực hiện nhiều vụ
tọn trà kiện sốt, nằm bảo cho tức át toàn giấu thông trên đều bản tình thái nguyên
gói quân bỏ sự nghiệp xây dần chủ nghề xá hội và bảo vệ tổ quốc.
Dự vội lẽ của đồng chỉ trình xuân trường, quý viên bán chấp hành chúng gương đàn,
Mỹ tự tình gủy, cũng có đồng chỉ quý viên bán thường vụ tình gủy, lấy đảo một số cơ quan nước vi,
cũng thân dân ra đình chung ta ra hoàn 2.
Chung ta ra hoàn 2, cán bộ khoảng cây sát ráo phòng công a tình thái nguyên,
đã hí xinh trong khí thực hiện nhiều vụ tài tổ rất phố nông xe, cường quán trều,
vào ngoài mục bốn tháng 2 năm nay không chẳng hay sảo, nè lại, nè m thức thường xấu giác
đối với ra đình đồng rồi và nhân dân.
Tại lấy truy tăng, đồng chỉ mới thứ tình huy trị xuân trường,
ất cẩn tría xẻ, mong ra đình đồng chỉ, nè đau thương, vượt qua nguy đau mất mắt,
đồng chỉ đợi này, công có tình, quý hợp, khẩn trường đều ra,
sự liên nghiêm miếng, lối tượng vi pham, phải tạo sự ra đem mạnh mẽ,
với các hành viên quay trường pháp luật và tính bạng người thực khi công vụ.
Cứ đời bị liên quà thức hiện nay đủ và ký thời các trễ đổ chính xách,
đối với thân hình ra đình chính xí, đen nghi cấp quay chính quần các sá phương và lực lượng
công văn, kế tục đầy mạnh giáo dục ý thức thường tôn phát luật trong trên dân.
Đồng chỉ mới thứ tình huy trễ đánh bàn, quan trường bỏ hài tục quốc,
hạvà, đợt truy tận hôm nay là vuynh dự cao quý,
là sự chiến của tục quốc, dành cho chúng ta giao khoảng 2.
Đồng chỉ kêu gói cán bộ, chính xí lực lượng công văn tình, kế tục nấu lực của gắng,
lấy tâm cưng tàn tôi với công vuyện của đồng chỉ lao khoảng 2, đẹp quốc tâm giıl dình quốc xong bình yên
và hải phúc cho cho dân dân.